皆さんペットがあっていますか俺なこいつは選んだよこいつアパートだから僕はペット
を飼えないんですよ
1品ぬ母言いたいあの本当にねもうね右腕と生活したいわけですでは猫のほうが好きな
んですけどで今日はそういうなんか
ペットが飼えない環境かよ置かれている
チルドレンがいると思うのでそんな君たちでも飼えるペットそうかしようと思います
オムニボット
ハローズーマーです
タカラトミーさんからですね
ってなんかすごいのはね2010年の日本おもちゃ大賞の大賞に受賞されているらしい
梅雨対象だぜどうなんですかね俺を渡りたいしためちゃ厳しいんでなるこういう
ワンッ
そっちはんっ
みたいなちょっと舐めだ作りだったら金賞だからちょっと本当に俺ねちょっと厳しく
から金賞でしょ
ベンリナーの変な中途半端な奴ではないとは思いますけど
おーぼハウス芸が家ドアなど何かけれないメッツ開けづらいんだけど買ったこれマジか
ねこれにどうなってるの
あと枝それだ
すごいやばいやばいなにかぶっている尻尾がすごい
こんな感じですね
パッと見こんな感じですよなんかすごいなんかまじかこれ意外としっかりできてるんだ
よ
尻尾とかをさあクリックですけれどこの電源入れてりてぃまず充電しないけど
まず中者のシーンですよおっで目が光ってる
4入ったの
でも入っていう
ううわあ嘘だろ俺の声だよ
覚え良い
うわーうわーや分大井字と思う
a
なになに
4ん
落ち0おいあぶないあぶないん
[音楽]
何なんか去年言葉をしゃべるぽいってはは
強いどんどん萌子出されたら
来るらしいんでちょっと行けます
お座り
中野ちょっといかれてるぽいなになになになになにコツ見て
[音楽]
思えないですか
ここだはっはっはこれこわいはーいっ
どういったんだろう
まあ大丈夫
遅い
おすわりおすわり
[音楽]
おいファちょっとなんだろなんだぞ
列車とズーマーと仲良くするためには根気が必要です
妻はつ言いたい子犬なので話しかける言葉には理解するのが難しいものもあります
あのなんかその話的で覚え覚えさせないとダメだしぃデス多い
大丈夫を置きます
何高校言いつつゲー
[音楽]
すごい可愛いなぁ
4ん
[音楽]
こんにちは
ん
眠そう
眠いの
ネタベンチがなかったのであんまりこの喋ってくるみたいなことでいなかったんです
けど
次会う時はねもう完璧にモールのいうこと全部聞いてるんだよ以上
はじめの新しいいいでしたじゃあ
[音楽]